welcome back to new rock stars the
falcon the winter soldier is complete
but
there are plenty of questions questions
like if isaiah bradley existed in this
universe who
else knew about him and why did they let
this happen
there have been characters throughout
the 20th century in the mcu
in positions of power who should have
known why didn't they stop this
exactly i'm eric boss here with mt how
you feeling mt
i'm feeling outraged i mean how could
they just know and just
just not let anything happen just
kidding i'm feeling great it's fine but
like
who could have known about isaiah
bradley is is there anybody out there
that
someone must have known i mean on
someone that we're you
like someone's holding things from us
who's who's holding that information
from us
hmm lying we are live with our listeners
on stereo right now uh they have
asked all kinds of wonderful questions
we're going to take them
uh but first we want to talk about this
whole idea of
who knew about isaiah bradley what was
interesting this week his series creator
malcolm spellman said in an interview
that he and his writers went deep into
the marvel history
uh and the historical implications of
who knew what when who was in power when
and based off of dr nagle's line in
episode three he said that you know uh
initially
the u.s government had control of isaiah
bradley he was an american
government soldier an american test
subject uh
and then at some point hydra was also
interested in super soldier serum hydra
had corrupted shield
and had its fingers its tentacles all
over the american government system
uh and that hydra kind of took over this
operation and then
hydra you know was starting to collapse
around civil war
especially with uh zemo plug in all the
winter soldiers
that were down there and plugging uh
that hydro kernel
uh now the problem with that is someone
in the american government throughout
the 20th century must have been aware
uh and uh so there have been figures
like nick fury like peggy carter
like howard stark like thaddeus ross uh
so
mt and i believe that thaddeus ross was
probably aware of isaiah bradley what do
you think oh yeah
yeah definitely i mean like you know
within the incredible hulk like a big
part of that movie is is them trying to
recreate the super soldier syndrome that
created
captain america and so with ross heading
up that project
he's got to know the history of the
serum and like how many like
the trials and errors of the past and so
he had to know of this sin
that um the united states government did
against isaiah bradley
so if anyone if there's anyone that i'm
very confident about
it's going to be him and also val val
just knows things now that we know val
so val probably knew i depending on what
her role was we don't really know
exactly
but um yeah i would say val and um
ross definitely probably had some
knowledge um
so we got those two there was also talk
of this nurse who
falsified his death report and allowed
him to escape there have been some
theories that dhonia madani could have
been that nurse
mt and i talked about this in friday's
episode that uh
it does work timeline wise and we think
dhoni madani had some history with the
super soldier serum and that's why she
was that was her initial role
for her to have been that exact nurse
feels a little curb your enthusiasm
style coincidental
but possible i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
exclude that possibility yeah it
definitely is possible and like i would
like um for for her to have to have that
time to have
that role to play in the series um
because it's really unfortunate that
she's just been relegated to a sick
and now dead woman um because of like
you know the deleted
um storyline um so yeah i would be
really cool to see
a tie to the super soldier serum legacy
with her as that nurse
um because you know she seems to be like
as far as we know she seemed to
be a really kind woman and you know she
went out of her way for everybody else
during her life
so it wouldn't be out of character for
her to be the one to
let isaiah go um but yeah you were
totally right it would have just been
too coincidental like oh so
you just happened to know the lady that
like i that sam um that helped sam's
you know right get the person that
inspired him all of a sudden it just be
too coincidental because the world is
too big for
for something that um specific to happen
so
you know yeah but um but i highly doubt
someone like um
like peggy carter knew um i think she
would
strongly object to any attempt to
replicate the super soldier serum
program after steve rogers like
that was probably a necessary move to
fight the nazis and to fight hydra
but after she assumed hydra was gone
i don't think that she would you know
be cool with them doing that to isaiah
bradley
and all the other soldiers they did that
too but i don't
go back and forth on nick fury though i
think
nick fury we forget he's a pretty uh
machiavellian dude
he's he allowed project insight to get
off the ground
uh and he has some strong reasons for
that i could see nick fury at least
knowing about this
thinking it's kind of messed up um you
know having arguments with people about
it but still
seeing that as like unnecessary
historical evil
that it's horrible that it happened but
it happened yeah and
you know and not yet about it because he
doesn't want to confuse the mission or
something like that
yeah i think that um you know with
shield being
a an organization that worked closely
with the government
i think he was just like this is a
terrible thing that happened but like
people knowing is not gonna make my job
easier so i'm just going to just
keep it in the past and like i'm not
happy about it but like
hakuna mat like there's nothing that we
can do about it it's just dying
and so he could have known like because
he's a shady he's a shady guy with a lot
of secrets so like he
right probably knew something um i mean
here's the thing we know bucky knew
bucky knew quite a bit he knew he saw
him in the korean war
you know so like i don't know he knew
the fullest extent of his incarceration
but i assumed bucky had checked in with
him afterwards
but even but didn't isaiah bradley say
like he only recognized him from like
decades earlier
like it seemed like that may have been a
long time since they had talked
yeah i thought the last time he saw him
was the korean war right and he almost
ripped off his arm
and all that stuff so i think he knew
that there was a soldier who had super
soldier serum and might know something
about i think the reason they went to
isaiah bradley was
to because he knows something about
super soldier experimentation and that
there might still be
versions of it out in the world so i
think bucky must have known that he was
being experimented on hmm i mean
it would it would make sense because he
was a hydra agent and a hydro asset
and like you know i'm sure hydra had
their eyes on isaiah bradley they wanted
him um before they actually got him
so you know it it's i think
i think bucky's reason for not telling
sam is the same nick fury or some of
these other folks like that is
this guy wanted to live peacefully in
private for the rest of his days
he didn't want any attention you know uh
and then isaiah bradley even said he's
like
no i don't want to do a press conference
right now because they're gonna come
kill me if they find out i'm still yeah
so sam kind of found a middle ground
solution with that uh
with that statue in the smithsonian um
and maybe that was enough for isaiah
bradley to be like it's it's kind of
made it look like
he's he was a past warrior that he's
paying yeah
as opposed to someone who's still alive
at baltimore he can go visit
yeah i mean he's just like hey i just
don't want to be a race from history but
i just don't want people to think that
i'm alive
because like you know having another
super soldier around
um just puts a target on your back and
like not only yeah with like news media
but like
like you said with uh you know various
entities whether it be
you know the government or just you know
evil people like you know hydro or
remnants of hydro or whatever the ten
rings
um wanting to um take him or
kill him um so yeah um
so uh let's take some questions from you
guys you patient stereo listeners
uh yes so what what if you had to make a
guess what do you think captain america
4 is going to be about
oh that is a greek i mean i would love
to see
i'm i you know we i know we talk about
zola a lot i like in like i'm always on
the zola train i would love to see
um the return of like you know those
classic cat villains
zola red skull um i definitely think
that red skull is coming back
feel it in my bones um because just
because of just the way that
those beams went up in um infinity war
and end game after the soul stone
um was um was
they they did the deed for the soul
stone um
it just i just think that he's like in a
wormhole somewhere and that there's
going to be some weird
um he's going to get be returned back in
on earth um at a particular set of time
but that's just me and my weird theories
but yeah i just want to see
sam face off against um hydra i
think that hydra's coming back but what
do you think what do you think
i think the coolest thing about captain
america is he fights the real world
historical battles of the era you know
so
uh was initially introduced during world
war ii um
i want to see cap fighting what is like
the current threat to
us right now [ __ ] white nationalist
terrorism
like i want to see him bring down these
[ __ ] groups
i want to see him punch what is today's
hitler right now you know
i let's see captain america punch that
dude in the face
uh i'm not talking about physical
protesters i'm talking about people
who are killing capital police and
violently burning [ __ ] uh on our capital
station of insurrection
that is straight up terrorism that is
not protest yeah so
let's make that distinction let's have
captain america on the front line of
that battle i don't give a
[ __ ] yeah i think a conversation about
something like that would be really
interesting and
and really topical like you said like
it's just totally right and i think that
um spelman in particular um
is is does like to talk about stuff like
that um and he would do a great i don't
think marvel will ever do that i think
that's probably a little too
uh political for marvel and i was
surprised they went as political as they
did in this show
but having them fight having them do
like stuff that we saw in watchmen i
don't think marvel's gonna go there for
quite some time oh my god i would love
for them to bring in the character the
hate monger
from the comics which is basically uh it
was he wasn't like in a kkk suit but it
was purple i think
um but it you know it's just a guy who
just uses people's hate to um
to be evil and so i think that'd be a
really
great character in a very uh you know
topically relevant
character to bring in but you know i
think that whatever
however captain america 4 comes out it's
going to be amazing because hey
we got sam wilson and b uh it's just
it's it's a huge deal
for sam wilson to be cap and so that
they're i feel like they're gonna
pour a lot more care into this captain
america
uh um movie than than most of their
other ones because it does mean a lot to
a lot of people
but before i continue thanks to blue
blocks for sponsoring this video if
you're like me you've been on your phone
or your computer or your tv more than
ever before screen time
all the time and i've noticed my eyes
starting to feel heavy and i was having
some problems sleeping well it's because
blue light damages our eyes and leads to
digital eye strain
some symptoms of digital eye strain
include blurred vision headaches and dry
or watery eyes for some folks this could
even affect your energy level
well blue blocks was created to fix this
problem and block out the blue light
with high quality lenses
blue blocks are evidence-backed and made
under optics laboratory conditions in
australia they have over 40 styles of
frames and come in prescription
non-prescription and readers so they
have frames for every need go to
blueblocks.com
new rockstars or just click on the link
below and you will get 20
off your order and free shipping
worldwide on orders over 115 dollars
get your energy back sleep better and
block out the unhealthy effects of blue
light with blue blocks that's b
l u b l o x dot com slash new rockstars
or just click on the link below
code automatically applied at checkout
for 20 off uh let's take another
question
by the end of the series wow do you guys
feel is
walker actually a villain or just
misunderstood
or just nuanced
um how should we look at walker at the
end of this series
um fascinating question i think
right now according to spelman after
this show
by the end of the finale it seemed like
the finale what was on screen
made him to look like a fully redemptive
character that he had
totally learned the error of his ways by
simply saving those
four or five grc officials that that
makes up for
violently butchering someone in the
street i
think to hear spelman talked about it i
think john walker getting away with it
was supposed to be a commentary on how
people like him
are able to kind of get away with stuff
yeah i think that
um i i really like that i think that you
know
we are like you said we are supposed to
get like this this sense of
yeah he he did learn a lesson throughout
the course of the series but i think
that the actual the root of the problem
the root of john walker's problem a lot
of his trauma and
in his his drive to
want to be this like ultimate soldier to
be this
like uh to be sort of i think he still
wants to be the next captain america in
a sense
because he wants to do right but like i
just think that there's a lot of mental
work that he's not
doing where he's going to keep crossing
those lines that we
kind of get teased um that with um in
falcon in the winter soldier
i think that we've only seen the
beginnings of
of john walker so yeah there's gonna be
a lot of more meant
terrible stuff i don't think it was
spellman's intent to validate
john walker's uh violence in latvia um
i think the intent was people like this
can get away with it i think we're still
meant to judge him
in that moment yeah um and uh
to wyatt russell's credit he is he gave
that character so much empathy
and he played it as you should play
villains you play it as someone who is
the winner of their own history
and the hero of your own story uh and i
thought the way he played it was so good
the fact that like it was very good you
you feel that kind of like
inner emasculation and that rage and
that powerlessness and that
rage again you know um to where you see
where he's coming from
uh but in terms of the character the way
it's being written no i don't think he
is a hero
right now i think he is that a morally
best and anti-hero
who we're kind of still afraid of
yeah he's uh he's gonna be doing some
really messed up
stuff um in the name of the government
uh because they need him too and so it's
gonna be really
great to see just how far um
and just how much john walker excuses
because he seems
to be the type of person just be like oh
it wasn't my fault it was out of my
hands
um so you know just to seeing that that
part of him um
evolving um or i guess devolving because
he's slowly degrading
um it's just really interesting and like
i don't i don't think anyone could have
played
john walker as well as uh russell did
russell knocked out the park i can't
think of a single actor
um but anyway that's me yeah uh let's
take another
why won't bucky go by as the white wolf
instead of the winter soldier anymore
any insights on that yeah i think monkey
is the white wolf and i think that's
what uh malcolm spellman kind of wanted
is like for him to no longer be
considered the winter soldier he is the
white wolf or just james began barnes
james barnes or bucky barnes or
something like that
um his winter soldier days are behind
him so yeah i
i hope that like the next title he
appears in he is just called the white
wolf like i want
black panther uh three or black panther
two to be black panther and the white
wolf or something like that you know
that'd be great
that would be sick or that'd be so sweet
or just like he gets his own spin-off
series where it's just called the white
wolf of wakanda uh that'd be fun
i'm telling you man a white wolf in the
war dogs of wakanda
all day every day like i love that idea
i think it'd be really cool like to see
like the white wolf or like i think that
for bucky to go by officially by the
white wolf in the mcu
i feel like we got to see him earn it
because we just we just accepted like oh
yeah he's called the white wolf that's
cool
but like i just want to get a glimpse of
like you know the transition of like
all right this is when you went from the
winter soldier to the white wolf
um i think that'd be great and i think
that that may be something that marvel
could be waiting for
before they officially named him the
white wolf but um another thing and
it could be mr mister remembering here
but in the
in the show didn't he say that he he
felt like a piece of the winter soldier
still lived inside of him um and that it
wasn't yeah he did say that at the end
of episode
five right yeah something like that i
think i remember him saying that so like
i feel like
that is probably that might end up being
significant because like
that that um wiring might not be 100
gone um and so um i
i this is a really wild thing that i i
wanted marvel to do
but like i really wanted marvel to use
the soul stone to somehow
remove the winter soldier from bucky
barnes in india in the world
to become his own his own individual
person that is 100
um and so like bucky just has this alter
ego that he has to
always face he's like you're the winner
soldier and i hate you but like
you are me and like it's it'd be really
cool to see um
that evolution and it would make bucky's
journey really interesting or
even more interesting because it's
already interesting uh but anyway that's
just me being uh
you know weirdo and cool
uh let's take another question what do
you think happens to carly's movement
now
there were a lot of supporters all over
the world apparently they can't just
disappear right i mean there's got to
have some kind of
group come out of that i agree
um and there was that one member of the
flag smashers who fell into the hudson
that they brought up at the end
so not all of them are dead even part of
carly's group
um or not yeah because the rest got boom
boomed by the butler
um yeah or had their faces like that
yeah i think they might go dormant for a
bit um
i don't see them uh like
maybe they could play a role in secret
invasion like they feel so disaffected
by the governments of the world that
they now
i mean the governments did lay off right
the grc did not pass the
the patch act i think yes um
and i think but now i can still see them
being like well we're still not getting
the resources we need and then like
being a group of humans who team up with
the scrolls or something like that and
secret invasion
uh or like the bathrooms the squirrels
who are trying to
dis destabilize the the world
governments
that'd be really interesting i would
love that would be a great angle to take
it
though i'm kind of like i feel like
people's reactions to the flax masters
have been
like kind of like either mixed to not so
great
so that i feel like kevin will be like
all right let's just forget that this
even happened like this is done you know
flax smashers are done
um at the most i think maybe they might
use the app in the app
technology sometime in the future maybe
that might come into play
um but the actual flag smashers i think
there's a shot in in um at the last
episode of falcon winner soldier that
sort of implied
that the followers were sort of
abandoning um
the uh the flag smasher cause because
like they they
showed the flag smasher masks on the
ground and then people walking away from
it
so like that i took that as a all right
this is like the flex measures we're
officially
done even though in in real life that's
not how movements die
like movements keep going despite you
know
the their figureheads leading like
leaders into martyrs and stuff
yeah exactly like we see in star wars um
after the original trilogy like the
empire didn't go away
100 after um uh the emperor died it's
like
there's still remnants but i think that
just the response to the flax mattress
hasn't been
um like they're not iconic marvel
villains they just sort of
came and went and like they served their
purpose and like that's okay and like
there's no no no no hate towards the
flag smashers really
um i i kovet obviously played a role but
like
you know i just think that kevin feig is
just like all right we're just going to
move on from here
yeah um and we too will move on uh we
have some questions we want to get
through but we're going to limit
ourselves to both each of us to 10
seconds just so we can get to more
questions because we want to okay
you think that it's possible that steve
is on the
peak the sword space station with nick
fury and nola scrolls
yes i think it is possible if that
conspiracy theory is true if not
i believe he is in wakanda yeah it's a
hqb anywhere so it's definitely possible
yes
i think my biggest question after the
season
wrapped up is when will we see joaquin
taurus again because
he is set up to be such a great
character and i really want to see him
soon
agreed i think we'll see him playing
falcon in captain america four
oh yes that's when we will get that big
reveal it's like all right here's
my new sidekick it's gonna be joaquin
torres
so yeah it's gonna be hopefully sooner
i'd love to see him pop up in like armor
wars or secret invasion or something
like that
but yeah that'd be super dope yeah my
question is what do you think
happened to the cap in the timeline he
stayed in
when he stayed with peggy yeah that's
what i think
this these rumors that another chris
evans captain america movie is happening
i think it's going to follow him through
20th century history so i
assume that he went to go free bucky
from hydra's clutches in siberia
uh and had some kind of cold war era
adventures with
bucky and peggy carter um i do like that
but i honestly think that he
just spent the rest of his days with
peggy and then
he just wanted to stop being a soldier
because that's what they that's what
tony told him to do
the whole time so yeah that's just me
yeah
absolutely i can see that too uh who do
you guys think is gonna help
zemo break out of prison because i think
it'd be a lot of fun
to see zemo and hammer
just to see their woods kind of coming
together i think they'd be a really fun
team so
but who do you guys think will break
zevo out of prison
uh hammer's a fun one i i assume
hammer's still
in prison um yeah like the two of them
sharing a cell together something could
be fun
i assume it's going to be uh like ross
ross or val
will uh make a deal with zemo it's
definitely going to be
ross or val um because it just makes the
most sense
i don't think that zemo is capable of
escaping the raft on his own
um and in in like because it's in the
middle of the ocean
uh a val or a uh a ross with you know
it just seems more likely but yeah yeah
i agree
well uh that is it for uh this episode
of our inside marvel q a we want to
thank everyone who asked questions for
all of you
watching we really appreciate that um be
sure to subscribe to new rockstars here
on youtube
follow me on instagram twitter at eavos
follow mt
mastertainment uh check out all of our
great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com
and as we said in friday's episode we
will be back every friday
uh everybody covering the biggest marvel
news going inside marvel with you
uh up until loki comes back and then
we'll be doing after shows for that so
this is gonna be a regular thing
we're excited we're not going anywhere
we love we're not going anywhere
never it never stops um but once again
thank you guys for joining us it's been
a delight talking about the falcon
winter soldier with you
uh and we will see you next time bye
[Music]
you